(groovy music)
- [Narrator] A drug used
in medication abortions,
the most common method to end a pregnancy,
is at the center of
the latest legal battle
over abortion access.
Federal judges in Texas and Washington
issued decisions that appear
directly at odds with one another.
One suspends approval of
the drug, Mifepristone,
by the Food and Drug Administration.
The other prevents the FDA
from restricting access to
the drug in some states.
Laura Kusisto is a national
legal affairs reporter
and leads abortion
coverage for the journal.
She explains what the decisions
mean and what comes next.
(groovy music)
(cheerful music)
- A Texas judge said that the FDA
had improperly approved a
drug known as Mifepristone.
He suspended that approval saying
that the FDA hadn't adequately considered
the safety of the drug.
They'd used the wrong procedure
for approving the drug.
The FDA had approved the drug
under a pathway that's
used to approve drugs
to treat life-threatening illnesses.
And the judge said,
"Most of us would not understand pregnancy
to be a serious life-threatening illness."
He also said that the
FDA had not adequately
taken into account possible concerns
about hemorrhage, about infection,
about mental trauma
that women could suffer.
So this ruling is really significant
because it affects abortion
access not just in Texas,
but around the country.
If the judge's ruling does go into effect,
that would mean that the pill
could be pulled from the market.
And so, this is really kind of one
of the first developments we've seen
that has potential nationwide significance
since Roe v. Wade was overturned
- It's completely outta
bound, what the judge did.
- Journalists and lawyers
were all still digesting this
really kind of blockbuster
ruling out of Texas,
and we got this other really
quite unexpected ruling
from a judge in Washington State.
It appears that the judge there is saying
that the FDA can't take
additional action at the moment
to further constrain access
to the abortion pill.
Now, that ruling only applies in states
that were parties in the lawsuit,
but in those states,
there's like a real tension
between the rulings of these two judges.
There's a concern that this
could really destabilize
the drug approval process in general,
if you have judges potentially
second guessing the FDA.
What I will say as a caveat
to that is that, you know,
this is abortion.
This is not a typical drug,
an uncontroversial drug.
This is something that
has been at the center
of a political firestorm in
this country for five decades.
It's not a perfect
analogy for other drugs.
- It is contrary to what makes
for good public health policy
to allow courts and politicians
to tell the FDA what it should do.
(groovy music)
- The Biden Administration
moved quickly to appeal the ruling.
They filed something
with the Fifth Circuit,
the Court of Appeals, asking
for them to stay the ruling.
And they've asked for them to
make a decision by Thursday.
That could go one of two ways.
They can give the Biden
administration what they want,
they can put this ruling
on hold or they can not.
They can allow it to go into effect.
And then in that instance,
I think you're very likely going to see
the Biden Administration
turnaround very quickly
and file an appeal with the Supreme Court.
- We stand by the FDA's
approval of Mifepristone
and we are prepared
for a long legal fight.
(groovy music)